En gerber precisamente estoy bueno,
estoy apoyando para toda la estrategia
del 2024.
Dentro de ellas fue pues todo el
desarrollo de la plataforma de bebidas
era muy Chiquita y además íbamos a tener
una reformulación. ¿Esto por qué sucede?
Porque salieron unos estudios que ahora
sí que se les recomienda a los pequeños
que cuando están más chiquitos.
Consuman prácticamente únicamente agua
con toque de fruta,
pero que este toque de fruta se a como
nectan, entre otras cosas.
Entonces ahí no se iba a estar pegando en
tema de portafolio, no,
entonces hubo unas claves que tuvimos que
descontinuar. Sin embargo,
también se hicieron,
pues todos los estudios para poder
ampliarla. No,
no sé si existe a gerber allá en España,
pero precisamente, o sea,
teníamos antes sólo juguitos y ahora ya
tenemos plataforma de smoothies de Agüita
con cereal.
Esto es como muy remedio mexicano.
Entonces pues también aquí yo soy
colombiana,
entonces aquí no sé si me suena de aquí
porque tengo niños pequeños,
pero creo que de Colombia me suena más.
¿Sí, sí, sí, sí, seguro, sí,
y es es una marca muy bonita, no?
Y precisamente ampliamos esta plataforma
para que diéramos pues más opciones hacia
la mamá,
no sé si bien o K no se pueden dar como
juegos en temprana edad.
¿Bueno,
ya una vez que esté más grande el niño
este que tenga como este incentivo de
estar hidratado que es de las principales
puntos,
no que necesitan los pequeños más con
luego todos los calores que hacen acá en
México y pues siempre es bien importante
mantener una hidratación buena, no,
para que no,
no se nos deshidraten y pase algo algo
más este algo pues perjudicial para su
salud, no, claro, es cultural, sabes?
Aquí no,
aquí los niños no son de tomar jugo,
zumos.
O sea y el van y agua, agua, agua,
agua en Colombia sí,
es muy típico los jugos,
por eso me suena más de allí. Ajá.
¿Y justo eso no?
Porque también precisamente ahorita lo
que está pasando con la categoría es que
están ampliando toda la plataforma de
Snacks, no sé,
antes nada más se tenían como unos pubs
que son como extruidos.
¿Y Ahorita ya sacaron mini Marías,
ahí tiene tostaditas y justo, no? ¿O sea,
México es de los países más snakeos,
entonces en vez de que la mamá le de la
galleta con azúcares,
grasas y entre otras cosas,
siempre es mejor darles una opción
saludable y que sea adecuada para ellos,
no? Entonces, bueno,
eso fue mi contribución por la parte de
de marketing siendo training.
Ya después pasé al área de ventas,
estuve atendiendo a nadro.
Nadro es el distribuidor de los
distribuidores más grandes de México de
medicamentos y bueno, de equipo médico.
Entonces yo entro desafortunadamente a la
semana,
mi jefe bueno decidió tomar retos para la
compañía,
entonces prácticamente me quedé sola,
más o menos 1 mes.
Y bueno,
como no teníamos toda esta información,
yo fui la encargada,
pues de otra vez construir todo,
no desde un catálogo,
este ver cómo se gestionaban los pedidos,
entender los procesos para poder llevar y
De igual forma la gestión eficiente de la
cuenta y ya con ello pues ya empezar a
desarrollarla, no este con adro, ahorita,
hoy en día si lo ves ya es un cliente
completamente diferente,
o sea tiene muchísimas plataformas para
poder crecer, desarrollar el negocio.
¿Sin embargo, o sea,
cuando recién yo la tomé apenas estaba en
sus pininos, no,
apenas iba como comenzando viendo que
activábamos y ya con ello,
pues también participamos con esta
cocreación conjunta con el cliente para
poder definir ahora sí pues que que iba a
seguir no?
Una vez que ya teníamos como esta
confianza recuperada,
porque igual un background importante es
que todos los cambios que habían tenido
les duraban 6 meses y se iban.
¿Pero hacias me dices y se iban entonces?
¿Pues ya también estaban como muy muy
molestos por esa parte, no?
Entonces logramos recuperar esa confianza.
Yo llevé a su top cliente que es grupo
RFP tiene farmacias acá en México como lo
son este farmatodo allá en por el sureste
con farmacias Unión, entre otras.
¿Entonces lo desarrollé y bueno,
igual aceleré la la venta en un 20%,
entonces ahí tuvimos una colaboración
conjunta muy buena, no?
Ya finalmente estuve en mi asignación de
ecommerce llevando a Amazon.
Entonces justo yo era como más parte
operativa para la Kia Count Manager,
pero este ayude mucho ejemplo para toda
la parte de gestión de pedidos.
Amazon es muy estricto en el tema de
órdenes, o sea,
si ellos te mandan una orden hoy.
Tienes máximo, por ponerte un ejemplo,
48 horas para poder confirmarle la orden,
pasadas esas 48 tienes otras 48 para
confirmarle cuánto le vas a entregar y
pasadas esas 48,
bueno ya para confirmar cita,
entre otras cosas no,
y si no cumples con estos tiempos en
específico se te cargan chargebacks.
¿Entonces evidentemente lo que nosotros
buscamos es eficientar los presupuestos
en todos los entornos, entonces?
Llevar esta gestión eficiente bueno
reducía o prácticamente erradicaba todos
estos cobros extras, no,
De igual forma nosotros con el Canal
Ecommerce,
Ahorita bueno está haciendo el boom y
está desarrollándose bastante,
pero cuando recién llegamos o sea se
surten de un centro de distribución
diferente al resto de las cuentas,
es un centro que tenemos aquí en
Tlalnepantla,
Cerquita de de donde están las oficinas.
¿Pero como no es el principal cedis no
siempre tenía stock,
entonces siempre teníamos un montón de de
problemas para poder surtir los completos,
no?
Entonces también dentro de mis proyectos
fue crear como este archivo maestro que
calculara conforme a los días de
inventario que tenían por clave,
o sea cada cuenta y hacia Amazon mercado
libre y justo.
¿Ver más o menos la proyección y el
forecast a dos meses para que nos
pudieran entregar ese stock al service y
poder este tener el producto disponible
para cuando llegara no? ¿Entonces,
ya posterior a a que terminé mi programa
ya fue que empecé como marketing
activator y soy justo como como
platicábamos tantito esta relación entre
marketing y ventas, no?
¿Cómo desarrollamos estrategias para
poder desarrollar las categorías?
En el caso de Gerber no sé cómo bueno
eficiente el portafolio de todos los
clientes de Del canal farmacias para que
los poquitos ese cavados que tenemos en
anaquel porque es muy chiquito,
sean verdaderamente los hi runners y los
de impacto,
no los que en mayor venta nos van atraer
y por tanto también rentabilidad,
entonces igual y por la parte de
suplementos hacer una categoría bastante
en desarrollo es cómo le damos la vuelta,
si ahorita igual no está en sus pininos,
entonces ver.
Qué nos hace falta,
qué está haciendo la competencia,
cómo usamos eso de benchmark,
cómo lo lo capitalizamos también nosotros,
no, entonces un poquito, esa sería mi,
mi trayectoria PA muy bien,
muchas gracias,
Eh por tu explicación y bueno,
muchas cosas,
no en en en poquito tiempo en 4 años Eh,
mucho,
mucho desarrollo y muchos proyectos.
Te felicito porque estás aprendiendo,
no de una gran compañía,
también haber entrado allí,
pues mira muy bien.
Por ese mérito también yo quisiera saber
en tu día a día en este cargo,
en estas responsabilidades que tienes,
qué qué, qué necesitas fortalecer,
qué ves que a lo mejor te hace falta,
que sería aquello que te hace falta.
Yo creo que precisamente me haría falta
como más esta parte de de conocimiento
para la parte de marketing, o sea,
para el máster que me enviaste.
Porque o sea, un punto personal. Pao,
yo en 2023 tuve un accidente,
me tuvieron que operar de la columna y
estuve cuatro meses de incapacidad.
Entonces ahí prácticamente perdí un mes
de mi asignación de operaciones.
Y 3 de marketing, no este.
Me ayudó mucho a la parte de
adaptabilidad porque tenía que entregar
mis entregables en esos 3 meses que me
quedaban,
pero no tuve la oportunidad completa full
de conocer como toda el área de marketing,
si bien ahorita estoy en estrecha
relación con con esa área,
por mi posición sí me gustaría aprender
un poquito más y igual no,
o sea para la parte comercial,
toda esta parte de negociación y demás.
Cuando fui este pecaria analista
realmente no negociaba cara a cara con
cliente,
no en la en mi asignación de de analista,
mi jefe me dio la oportunidad de llevar
una misión de llevar una categoría
Chiquita, no con una compradora,
y ahí tuve la fue mi primer acercamiento
como de negociación cara a cara,
pero o sea,
han sido como oportunidades muy pequeñas,
no igual cuando fui training sólo en la
de ventas y poquito en la de ecommerce,
entonces si me gustaría desarrollar.
Ambos esto los criterios, vale,
yo pienso también este máster tiene tiene
esa potencia que te da esas herramientas,
esas habilidades en el área de marketing,
pero también tiene la parte comercial,
no desde un punto de vista,
sobre todo más de negociación,
que eso te va a ayudar mucho,
sobre todo a estar actualizada. ¿Vale,
y Fíjate,
nuevamente ratifico lo que te he dicho y
te voy a explicar el porqué y te voy a
hacer una similitud, mira,
tú tienes tu carrera de base,
es Ingeniería Industrial, no?
¿Correcto, vale?
Luego estás trabajando en el área de
marketing,
estás trabajando en una gestión comercial
en este momento,
entonces es allí donde tú vas a crecer.
Tú vas a crecer primero en esta área de
marketing de Nestlé,
que es irte a una vicepresidencia o una
gerencia. Vale,
entonces esto es como cuando un niño
empieza a caminar.
Un niño empieza primero a gatear,
luego se para a caminar a dar pasitos y
luego sí, sale corriendo.
Hacer 1 n b a es como tirar al bebé a
correr.
Es muy duro o K vale, no, no puede ser,
hay que seguir como 1111 norma un
conducto regular de aprendizaje para que
en realidad te sirva. Vale, de acuerdo,
listo.
Si a lo mejor si tú me dijeras no es que
vengo de una carrera de base de marketing,
ya tengo tema de marketing, pues ahí sí,
oye,
busquemos otra cosa que a lo mejor te
pueda ayudar, pero la idea es eso,
enriquecerte paso a paso y en orden y yo
pienso que lo mejor es eso,
que te que te decantes por el área de
marketing.
¿Porque es tu paso a seguir,
tu paso siguiente seguramente que si yo
te pregunto, Oye,
qué opciones hay de crecimiento hay en
Nestlé? ¿Donde estás?
Me dirás que a lo mejor algún cargo en el
área de marketing, cierto, sí, sí, sí,
luego otra cosa,
porque yo me imagino Andrea,
no sé si a lo mejor te vayan,
sí que te ofrezcan el M b a y te van a
decir tú tienes que hacer el M B a y Mira
Métete a hacer el m b a por lo que te
decía, es un tema de moda.
El M b a se ha vuelto tema de moda,
entonces hoy en día ofrecen m b a por
cualquier cosa super baratos,
cuando 1 m b a también es costoso. O sea,
para que un programa sea de verdad 1 m b
a tiene que costar mínimo mínimo 15000
dólares y eso es muy barato.
¿Cualquier m b a que te digan porque los
hay EH, 4005 1000 dólares es mentira,
no es 1 m b a porque también el m b a va
dirigido al gerente general de la empresa,
al director de negocios, Sabes?
Al country Manager,
este es el perfil que debe hacer 1 m b a
vale y lo ideal, lo que te decía,
lo ideal es es importante que esa persona
que va al envié ya tenga un máster,
sean marketing, sean logística,
sean finanzas,
pero ya tenga de base un máster. ¿Vale,
es el conducto normal, vale? ¿Bueno,
tú me comentabas ayer Andrea,
que tú estabas mirando sobre todo,
querías hacerlo en México,
cuéntame un poquito si tienes opciones YY
por qué?
¿Bueno,
ahorita lo estoy viendo más en México
precisamente por el desarrollo
profesional que todavía podría
desarrollar acá ejemplo,
hablándote específicamente en este no,
cuando te expatrían a otro Estado,
bueno a otro país,
perdón por lo regular ya son puestos más
altos, no? O sea no,
no tenemos la oportunidad de ejemplo,
yo ahorita siendo coordinadora de poder
este estar viviendo una experiencia fuera
del país.
Pero aún así, Pau, o sea,
no estoy cerrada. De hecho, o sea,
me gustaría mucho también conocer las
opciones que que existen. No,
porque sé ejemplo que cuando estudias en
otro país la verdad es que me encantaría
YY justo no saber qué.
¿Qué bondades tendría el estar estudiando?
¿No,
porque sé que cuando estás estudiando es
mucho más fácil solicitar tu visa,
o sea para que estés realmente legalmente
viviendo allá, no? ¿O sea,
así que toda en regla o KY,
pero te gustaría hacer algo presencial
también?
Sí, sí, sí, sí. ¿O sea,
yo estoy abierta a todas las
posibilidades que que existen entonces,
pero por ejemplo,
si te sale algo presencial aquí en España,
qué pasaría con tu trabajo en Nestlé?
Tendría que bueno,
pues ya darle las gracias, no,
prácticamente vale.
Aquí también te hago una una salvedad,
porque aquí es sí,
es más para que te fijes un poquito en el
perfil. Hoy en día,
la formación presencial cien por cien
presencial está enfocada a un perfil
junior.
¿Vale o K? Sobre todo,
el COVID hizo que hubiera un boom de la
formación online. Pero realidad,
la formación online existe mucho tiempo
atrás. Entonces,
sobre todo online to Network.
En el intercambio profesional,
los trabajos en equipo lo haces con
alumnos de diferentes países,
gente que trabaja,
que viaja y que no tiene tiempo.
En un máster presencial te vas a
encontrar al alumno super junior de 23
años,
que se acaba de graduar y mientras se
encuentra esa posición en esa buena
compañía se toman ese año para venir a
estudiar presencialmente.
Entonces aquí tienes que poner una
balanza con quién quieres aprender y
hacer trabajo en equipo con un alumno
junior,
donde seguramente tú vas a ser la persona
que les vas a aportar tus tus
experiencias en Nestlé o quieres estar en
un aula enriquecida donde puedas aprender
e interactuar con gente de Argentina,
de Chile, de México, de España.
Vale,
porque esa es la principal diferencia.
¿Vale de un formato cien por cien online
a un formato presencial listo el perfil
del alumno? Vale, vale,
lo digo porque he tenido muchos alumnos
que han empezado. Oye, sí,
yo hice un máster presencial y yo era la
que contaba,
yo era la que tenía 10 años de
experiencia,
los demás eran superjunior recién
graduados. Vale eso,
Fíjate en ello porque es importante que
lo tengas en cuenta,
da igual en cualquier país que elijas,
pero es así la metodología presencial.
Es ese enfoque para esa persona que pues
todavía no tiene esas responsabilidades
que tienes tú en Nestlé, vale,
por ejemplo,
bueno y cuéntame una cosa a nivel de
instituciones,
aquí en España has mirado opciones,
en España solo nos tienes A o b s
cuéntame un poquito.
¿Cómo fue que te salió la publicidad o la
información? Pues fue fue Instagram,
yo ahorita estoy bueno cotizando o bueno
revisando y enviándome información a
ciertas universidades.
Ejemplo acá en México en Vialtec.
Envial Itam.
¿El del iPad me gustó muchísimo,
pero bueno,
es formato presencial y justo como bien
comentas,
pues ya el perfil del estudiante ya es
mucho más grande, no?
¿Porque hace todo el sentido de lo que tú
me cuentas, o sea,
ya es para cuando ya estás mucho más
envuelto en esta trayectoria profesional
y que ya es para dar tu siguiente paso,
entonces bueno,
para ella ya no envío información,
pero a donde sí en mi información fue al
IE University, aquí en España no?
Ajá.
Entonces a lo mejor YY por eso fue que me
salió la publicidad de de o b S y con el
IE es presencial. No entiendo, entiendo,
también tienen online,
o sea también tienen formatos online,
pero no sé si sea máster,
tengo que revisar Master cien por cien en
línea,
creo que es alguna otra especialización o
curso sí, o sea, sí vi que era n b a.
¿Ajá e igual, o sea,
también tenían ciertos formatos, no,
que sí era part time, full time,
en inglés, en español, pero sí, perfecto,
bueno,
voy a empezar mi estás estás evaluando
muy bien, EH?
Lo estás haciendo con buenas
universidades.
¿Por qué hago esta pregunta?
¿Porque la formación online se ha visto,
se ha vuelto un boom, Eh?
Y un alumno mexicano me enseñó esta
palabra y hay muchas escuelas, Papito.
¿Sí, vale,
entonces hay que tener mucho cuidado,
sobre todo en sobre todo en los envíos,
no cuando te ofrezcan 3 envíes en 1 más
cursos de inglés,
un envíe un curso de inglés no tiene
sentido,
tienes que hablar inglés si quieres hacer
1 n b a Sabes,
entonces es eso que te deje? Como no.
Que conozcas la institución,
que sea una institución de prestigio.
Tú has estudiado en una muy buena
Universidad de tu país,
tienes que seguir ese crecimiento en
calidad,
nunca bajar la calidad por más descuento
beca que te den, porque eso sí,
estas instituciones te van a dar una beca
espectacular y el máster te queda en 3000
dólares. ¿Aquí tienes que preguntarte,
oye,
por qué un máster en el TEC de Monterrey
me vale 200000 pesos y aquí me lo dejan
en no sé €3000 vale,
hay que tener cuidado con eso y siempre
le recomiendo a ustedes antes de mirar
sobre todo eso, qué descuento,
qué beca me dan?
¿Que se fijen en el respaldo empresarial
y en el respaldo académico,
porque eso te va a decir qué tanta
calidad hay detrás del estudio y qué
tanto prestigio vas a poder poner en tu
currículo? Vale de acuerdo, sí.
Entonces, En este sentido,
nosotros somos o b s Business School que
quiere decir Online Business School.
Nacimos en el año 2006,
con lo cual llevamos 19 años haciendo
másters y en B a cien por cien digital no
nacimos con el COVID,
tenemos una trayectoria mucho más atrás,
19 años mejorando y perfeccionando este
método de enseñanza.
Esto hace también que o b s lidere los
principales ranking de formación.
¿Si a TI te gusta mirar ranking,
verás siempre a o b s liderando ranking
por esta trayectoria tan importante, vale?
De acuerdo respaldo empresarial,
es solidez en la institución que no vaya
a ser que te metas a tu maestría,
los 3 meses te lo cierren,
para eso hay que buscar un buen respaldo
económico o empresarial.
O B s pertenece a la multinacional
planeta,
No sé si a TI te suena Grupo Planeta o
editorial planeta. No, no,
planeta es una editorial muy importante,
De hecho,
la mayor editora de libros en español es
planeta, editorial planeta se llama,
tiene más de 60 años de historia.
Y adicional a esto,
el Grupo Planeta tiene dos áreas más,
unas comunicaciones.
¿Tienen canales de televisión aquí en
España? Periódicos.
No sé si te suene a atresmedia,
a tresmedia es una productora
internacional que hace muchas de las
series y películas de Netflix.
Es de planeta. Y adicional a esto,
planeta tiene un área que se llama
planeta, formación y universidades,
que es donde estamos nosotros.
Vale,
en el grupo de formación de planeta somos
22 instituciones que hacemos estudios en
diferentes ámbitos profesionales y
diferentes metodologías.
Nosotros o b s tenemos un valor
importantísimo y totalmente diferenciador.
Y es que somos la única Business School
en El Mundo online que tiene como partner
académico a esta Universidad.
la Universidad de Barcelona.
No sé si conocías y habías escuchado
hablar antes de la Universidad de
Barcelona, sí.
Sí, sí, vale,
es una Universidad de muchísimo prestigio
aquí en España,
la principal Universidad pública.
Pero es que en tu caso,
al ser una alumna internacional,
lo importante son los rankings en el
ranking questar la Universidad de
Barcelona está como la número 1 a nivel
mundial en idioma español. Vale,
entonces esta Universidad compite
directamente con las grandes, Harvard,
Cambridge, Oxford. Vale, aquí en España,
el ranking Shanghái posiciona a la
Universidad de Barcelona como la mejor
Universidad para estudiar en este país.
Vale, perfecto.
Esto hace partner académico que quiere
decir mira es un convenio que firma el
rector de la Universidad de Barcelona con
el Presidente de planeta.
Firman este Convenio de colaboración para
crearnos a nosotros a o b s Business
School y que de esta manera tú estudies.
Un programa primero que está totalmente
blindado porque obviamente ellos
respaldan,
ellos titulan ellos auditan también para
respaldar la calidad de la institución.
Entonces te beneficias por eso,
por un blindaje de cualquier programa que
quieras elegir.
Pues estudiar aquí con nosotros y también
te vas a beneficiar por la doble
titulación,
porque al finalizar los estudios vas a
recibir dos cartones,
dos títulos de máster.
Esto que te estoy enseñando son las
publicaciones que yo hago en LinkedIn.
Yo solo compartir lo que los alumnos
publican entonces,
información que es totalmente pública.
Si quieres ver ejemplo de los títulos,
los puedes ver aquí.
Hay alumnos que lo publican y alguno he
compartido yo.
Entonces recibes esos dos cartones,
1 que te emite o b,
S y el otro te lo emite directamente a la
Universidad de Barcelona.
Título de máster de formación permanente
en en dirección de marketing y gestión
comercial. Mira, aquí los puedes ver,
vale un título que te emite o b,
S y el otro título te lo emite
directamente a la Universidad de
Barcelona.
El título que te emite la Universidad de
Barcelona no dice que es online.
Es un título exactamente igual al de los
alumnos que vienen de aquí a Barcelona a
estudiar presencialmente.
Porque ese título tiene 60 créditos,
que es la equivalencia en horas para que
el programa sea considerado como máster,
maestría o Magister.
¿1500 horas debe tener el programa vale?
O K o K ahora ese título que te emite la
Universidad de Barcelona es un título que
se apostilla,
se compulsa mediante el Convenio de La
Haya y de esta manera tiene total
legalidad para ejercer tu carga
profesional en México o en más de 150
países. ¿Perfecto, vale?
Ahora este es un título que tiene un
carácter propio o profesionalizante.
¿No sé si alguna vez habías escuchado
hablar de este término, no?
Vale,
te voy a explicar los programas que has
estado mirando en México.
Son programas que duran 2 años o 1 año,
2 años, 2 años.
Lo que pasa es que en América Latina la
mayoría de máster programas que le llaman
máster o maestría,
duran 2 años porque tienen un enfoque
investigativo y teórico.
Vas a ver mucho más contenido teórico y
va enfocado a la investigación.
Para hacer un doctorado, por ejemplo,
mientras que aquí en Europa hay dos tipos
de másteres,
están los máster de corte oficial y están
los máster de corte profesional como este.
¿Qué quiere decir profesional?
Quiere decir primero que es un plan de
estudio que dura solo 1 año,
porque se enfoca en ese año en darte a TI,
sobre todo, habilidades directivas,
pensamiento estratégico, herramientas,
actualización. No vemos teoría,
no sé si me entiendes.
¿Vale o K no? Sí,
porque aquí hay dos tipos de alumno.
Exacto, es más práctico.
Ahí el alumno que es directivo de Nestlé
y que necesita herramientas,
actualización, negocio,
sobre todo estrategias de negocio,
hace un máster de corte profesional o
propio como éste.
Y el alumno que su objetivo es ser doctor,
hacer un doctorado,
dedicarse a la docencia.
Él tiene que hacer un plan de estudio más
teórico e investigativo que dura 2 años.
Esa es la gran diferencia a nivel de
legalidad,
los dos títulos tienen legalidad mediante
la compulsa de La Haya.
Este título es legal para trabajar en
México y en más de 150 países. ¿Vale o K?
Alguna pregunta hasta aquí no, no, no,
todo muy claro, muchas gracias, perfecto.
Bueno,
voy a explicarte el tema de comunidad
alumno,
porque aquí también hay algunas cosas muy
interesantes y que te pueden servir mucho.
O b s tiene una comunidad alumni con más
de 42000 personas en más de 80 países.
Vale,
entonces nosotros te damos de alta en la
Comunidad alumni porque tu vínculo con o
b s es un vínculo de por vida no dura
solo 1 año, no es de por vida.
En esta comunidad alumni tú tienes acceso
a sesiones totalmente gratis.
Durante toda tu vida profesional puede
solicitar sesiones de Executive Coaching,
Project, mentoring,
diagnóstico de currículum, hay workshop,
por ejemplo, de negociación, de liderazgo,
de gestión, de equipo.
Puedes participar de todas las
actividades e incluso que son muy buenas.
Siempre sale una agenda brutal con las
actividades y sobre todo el tema
networking lo potenciamos muchísimo
porque actualmente tenemos comunidad
alumni en estos 8 países.
Incluso incluido tu país. Por supuesto,
estas personas que están aquí son alumnos
nuestros que hemos designado como
Presidente de las Comunidades Alumni y es
un poco para que tú veas cómo es el
perfil de alumno que te encuentras en o b
s por ejemplo, Kareli Munarres.
Ella fue nuestra presidenta alumni en
México,
ella es la directora de comunicaciones en
Telefónica México.
¿No sé si te suene esta compañía,
es como Movistar, no vale? Sí.
Vale,
ese es el tipo de alumno que te
encuentras,
directivos de muy buenas empresas.
La Presidenta alumni de Costa Rica,
por ejemplo,
es la Directora de Operaciones de
Mondelez,
que no sé si Mondelez compite con Nestlé.
Yo creo que algunos productos sí son
competencia, no algunos,
sólo los chocolates. Sí, vale,
y luego por ejemplo, el señor de Ecuador,
Carlos Aguilera.
Él es Director nacional de ventas de la
multinacional Valle Ardof,
que no sé si conoces esta compañía.
Sí, no,
excelente para todo el tema de skin.
Exacto, sí, vale,
y como ves son perfiles comerciales.
Este es el tipo de alumno que te
encuentras en o b s directivos que
trabajan en importantes multinacionales.
De hecho,
Carlos Aguilera estudió este mismo máster,
dirección de marketing y gestión
comercial. Vale,
y lo que yo te comentaba el día de ayer,
mira, este es nuestro perfil de LinkedIn,
que no sé si lo conoces.
Sí, sí, sí, sí,
vale 17000 personas si te vas a México,
en México hemos formado a más de 1162
mexicanos,
entonces incluso profesores que dan
clases en el TEC de Monterrey,
en la anáhuac, se han formado aquí en o B.
S gente de Amazon, de Nestlé,
de Johnson y Johnson. Vale,
tú puedes poner.
Pues lo buscas,
ahora en un ratito pones la empresa y te
salen personas,
pues interesantes para que veas cómo es
el perfil del alumno.
Yo pienso que eso es lo más importante a
destacar de verdad que te formes,
que estudies con alumnos que estén
trabajando y que te aporten conocimientos.
Yo tuve alumnos, por ejemplo,
eso fue hace un tiempito que estaban
haciendo las Marketplace en de Nestlé en
el Cono Surchil Uruguay, Argentina,
entonces eso es interesante,
participar con alumnos pues que son de a
lo mejor de tu misma empresa,
pero están en otros países.
¿No, no sé si pensó,
para ti es interesante, no? Sí, bastante,
bastante cierto, a mí me parece que sí.
Mira, hay alumnos en Ecuador, en España,
Colombia, Chile. Vale, esto es brutal,
ajá. Y luego las comunidades también,
porque hacemos encuentros presenciales
allí,
en los países se hacen actividades
presenciales, precisamente para eso,
para que ustedes fortalezcan networking,
para que se den a conocer.
De hecho,
en mayo va a haber un alumni de es
especial para la el club Alumni de Perú y
de España,
pero pueden participar todos los alumnos.
Y está invitado este señor que no sé si
te ha salido alguna vez en redes.
Mario Alonso, vale que es espectacular,
este señor es es.
Una eminencia en temas de investigación y
de y de El potencial humano.
Son actividades gratis,
están compartiendo con este señor,
haciéndole preguntas, debatiendo, o sea,
son actividades que hacemos continuamente
para los clubs alumnito, por supuesto,
tienes que puedes participar totalmente
gratis sin tener que pagar nada. ¿Vale?
¿Bueno,
voy a explicarte la metodología de
estudio y quiero hacerte una pregunta,
experiencia online,
cuéntame cómo ha sido tu experiencia,
qué has hecho a nivel online?
Bien, De hecho,
precisamente cuando empezó la pandemia yo
todavía estaba estudiando.
Entonces sí me sí,
me tocaron mis últimas materias
prácticamente online, no, o sea,
cómo te fue, cómo te fue bien, bien, bien,
bien, no se fue casi 1 año, porque bueno,
nosotros nos confinaron acá en marzo yo
terminé diciembre,
entonces estuve prácticamente casi 1 año,
no sé si es.
Sí, yo creo que es el doble de enfoque,
de responsabilidad,
pero siempre he sido muy ordenada con con
mis estudios, o sea, sí me gusta,
aunque sea online, pasarlo a a físicos,
escribir, tomar notas y todo no. ¿O sea,
para que para que todo este conocimiento
realmente se se me se me permee a mí no,
porque muchas veces si nos quedamos nada
más con online, bueno, al menos a mí,
mi método de aprendizaje es más como
kinestésico no? O sea,
tengo que hacerlo yo perfecto,
entonces bien, o sea,
me lo voy a adaptar bien.
Vale,
de todas maneras te explico algunos tips
importantes porque este no es un curso a
distancia donde todo esté pregrabado y tú
solo vayas a ver vídeos.
No es totalmente diferente. O sea,
De hecho hay gente que entra con miedo a
una metodología online porque piensa que
es eso, ver vídeos y trabajar solo,
no aquí.
Es en vivo y en directo,
no trabajamos con nada pregrabado son
clases en vivo y sobre todo trabajamos
con el método del caso, es decir,
no es tanto que te aprendas teoría para
luego responder un cuestionario no,
sobre todo cada semana hay un caso
empresarial, método Harvard,
no sé si suena a un método del caso, sí,
sí, sí,
así es como trabajamos cada semana.
Hay un caso que ustedes tienen que
desarrollar,
esta es la forma en la cual les evaluamos,
vale, perfecto.
Bueno, voy a centrar en esta página,
no sé si si la viste en el plan de
estudio.
De todas maneras yo te la explico,
vale beca o s impacto fueron unas becas
que sacamos el año pasado para aquellos
proyectos finales de todos los máster que
tenemos en o b s que son más de 30 máster.
¿Ustedes tienen que hacer un proyecto
final?
Ese proyecto final de Máster va a ser un
proyecto enfocado a un caso empresarial
real.
Vale,
entonces el año pasado se decidió premiar
a aquellos proyectos que impactaran en el
área social o en el área sostenible y
ganaron estos 3 proyectos. De hecho,
amatis sostenible es un proyecto de una
chica colombiana radicada en México.
Ella tiene una un comerc,
estudió el máster en marketing digital y
tiene un ecommerce superlindo míralo
cuando puedas amerti sostenible son
sandalias,
bolsos preciosos fabricados en Colombia.
Entonces ella tiene un proyecto social
con sus fabricantes de Colombia.
Ganó también big Baca,
que es un proyecto de un señor mexicano
que estudió el el máster en
transformación digital y tiene un
proyecto espectacular a nivel de datos a
nivel de inteligencia artificial para
todo el tema agroindustrial.
Y también ganó esta empresa de Costa Rica
con manejo de residuos. Vale,
entonces son temas que te pueden servir
mucho,
que incluso si haces un proyecto que
impacte en estos temas, pues mira,
puede ser que se te devuelva todo lo que
pagaste por el máster. ¿Al final,
vale o K?
Porque aquí se promueve sobre todo eso,
que tú hagas un máster que de verdad
apliques,
que de verdad pongas en práctica y que te
sirva la mayoría.
Lo que le pasa a los másteres teóricos de
de nuestros países de América Latina son
eso que se quedan en mucha teoría.
¿Un directivo, ya te digo, directivos,
es muy difícil que te encuentro,
un directivo necesita los conocimientos,
ya no se puede ligar tanto tiempo a 1 a 1
metodología, 2 años presenciales,
porque a lo mejor tiene cargo,
responsabilidad, tiene que viajar, claro,
ahí ya se ve limitado, vale?
Bueno, este es el plan de estudio. ¿Ah,
bueno,
yo te iba a hacer una pregunta importante,
Andrea,
yo no sé si lo te lo pregunté ayer,
tú cuándo quieres iniciar el máster?
Bueno,
precisamente estaba viendo que iniciaba
abril, no, o sea,
no tendría teme iniciar ya más bien tenía
duda porque ves que inician ejemplo en a
inicios de mes y que pues ya voy un
poquito tarde no,
pero no sé si únicamente se inicia en
abril, o sea, hay otras ventanas,
ejemplo septiembre también he visto que.
Más menos inicia por allá.
Pero ese también te quería preguntar,
eso sí, mira, hay un inicio, o sea,
si tú quisieras que te incluyéramos en el
que acaba de empezar podemos hacerlo
porque se acaba de pasar.
La semana pasada hubo una masterclass,
esta semana es vacaciones,
entonces los alumnos se están
actualizando ahorita y luego hay otra
masterclass,
la otra semana o K si quisieras hacerlo
ahora como para aprovechar el tiempo,
yo podría solicitar que me abrieran un
cupo para ti.
O K o K o K, sino el sino.
El siguiente programa está previsto que
inicie en octubre o K no nos tocale.
¿Cómo ves las fechas?
Pues o sea no tendría tema en comenzar
prácticamente ya únicamente necesitaría
revisar tema de presupuesto.
También me gustaría preguntarte,
veo que precisamente no está valuado en
€7500, pero este pago es este,
no se mensual semestral.
Pues mira, yo te explico una cosa,
Déjame solamente voy a mandar un un
mensajito aquí a mi responsable,
porque justo para ahora abril hay un cupo,
mira si esto no se asigna y son las 8:00.
H, Bueno,
nos tocaría correr un poquito con la
matrícula, te explico,
yo tengo un alumno como ahora estamos en
esto en Sierra admisiones y nosotros
empezamos con mucha antelación,
yo tengo un alumno un cupo de diciembre
que este chico nos solicitó cambiarse al
envío, o sea,
se matriculó hace mucho tiempo y por tema
laboral se se cambió al envío.
Entonces ese cupo.
Lo tengo que reasignar,
le acabo de preguntar a mi responsable si
ya lo habían asignado o si te lo podemos
dar a ti porque tiene ayuda financiera
bastante alta.
¿Vale o K nos saltamos a esa parte de de
costo o te hablo más de la metodología,
no, sí, sí, sí, sí, cuéntame, cuéntame,
sí, sí, me gustaría conocer sí detalles,
vale o k bueno, el programa,
entonces tú lo viste?
Giratorno sobre todo a darte las
herramientas claves en el área de
marketing y ventas para poder.
Crear estrategias, pues, exitosas,
no vinculadas, pues,
a a todos estos análisis que tú hagas.
El programa gira entorno,
adaptación al mercado, gestión de equipos,
una visión estratégica y sobre todo,
investigación. Vale,
Estas son las tema de ranking del
programa,
las competencias que vamos a desarrollar.
Este es el perfil del alumno que tanto te
ha recalcado. Mira,
incluso está Nestlé sobre todo esto,
permite hacer un programa que te permite
interactuar,
aprender con alumnos de estas empresas,
porque es donde en realidad vas a
aprender de ese de ese debate,
de por qué tomar una decisión con estas
personas,
no con alumnos que a lo mejor no tengan
tanta experiencia, vale,
método de estudio, método del caso,
vale todo es super práctico,
análisis de casos,
foros de debate y toma de decisiones.
A ti te toca viajar por tu trabajo o no,
verdad o sí.
No, todavía no vale,
si tuvieses que viajar no hay ningún
problema,
tú vas a contar con esta persona.
Program manager es una coordinadora de
aula que te va ayudar en tema del día a
día. Por ejemplo,
si alguna semana no llegas a entregar
algún trabajo a tiempo,
si te desconectas del máster por
cualquier motivo,
te puedes apoyar con la Program manager
para recuperar aquello que no hayas
podido desarrollar óptimamente. ¿Vale,
hay hay flexibilidad al ser online en
flexibilidad porque obviamente eso es
para gente que trabaja, vale?
Estas actividades son actividades
adicionales al máster que las puedes
hacer cuando tú quieras, vale,
incluso las puedes hacer,
pues un fin de semana y vale la pena
porque son buenísimas.
Hay un Button que se llama personal
branding,
son actividades que no hacen parte del
plan de estudio, son adicionales,
pero son muy buenas.
No sé si alguna vez has trabajado en tu
marca personal, no, no, no, no,
pero sí sí, sale bastante interesante. Sí,
es importante,
sobre todo para destacar en Nestlé,
seguir creciendo,
aprovechar que estás en una excelente
compañía.
¿Son herramientas que te sirven para ese
crecimiento profesional, personal,
branding, data, historytelling no,
tú tienes que hacer presentaciones,
no entiendo que muchas, cierto? Sí,
data historytelling te va a ayudar a ser
mucho más profesional,
a saber simplificar gráficos,
ser más asertiva a la hora de presentar
datos.
Luego tenemos otro que se llama
pensamiento creativo,
innovación y los dos últimos son en
inglés,
creando la marca profesional y
fundamentos financieros y por cada
bootcamp que tú vayas haciendo te emiten
certificado, no tienes que pagar nada.
¿Son gratuitos,
están incluidos y te van dando
certificados y finalizas las actividades
evaluativas que no es obligatorio,
es opcional, EH?
Puedes hacer por ejemplo los dos Boot
Khan ahora y luego al final el resto como
tú quieras. Vale,
hacemos una demo introductoria al campus
virtual.
Nosotros trabajamos con una plataforma
que se llama Blackboard,
no sé si maneja este blackboard a lo
mejor en la carrera perfecto ya la sabes,
manejar entonces necesita hacer la
intención.
Vale y luego estos serían los módulos,
cada módulo dura un mes de estudio,
es muy organizado, no ves todo de golpe,
sino que vemos un tema por mes,
vale siempre antes de que inicie el
módulo lo primero que hacen los
profesores es enviarte un cronograma para
que tú organices tu agenda sepas los días
que hay clase,
cuando inicio un trabajo y cuando se debe
entregar.
¿Por norma general trabajamos con una
Master class por semana que es una clase
en vivo y en directo,
así como me estás viendo a mí y esa clase
va a ser a las 11,
qué horas tienes ahorita 12 y 10 no?
¿Sí, ajá, pues la clase es a las 11,
depende del horario,
porque ahorita estamos manejando horario
de verano, sería las 11,
cuando sea horario de invierno va a ser a
las 12:00 H de México,
vale o K qué te parece la clase una vez a
la semana a esa hora cómo la ves?
Está perfecto,
o sea yo podría solicitar este apoyo,
o sea que me dejaran esa ahorita no YY
así no pasa nada.
Vale, de todas maneras,
si no pudiste ver la clase, o sea,
a lo mejor no estuviste al cien por cien
en ella todas las clases se van quedando
guardadas en el campus,
de manera que la puedes repetir por la
noche o volver a ver las veces que tú
quieras. Vale o K perfecto.
Y luego lo más importante del máster son
los casos,
siempre el día martes inicio un caso que
se debe entregar el siguiente martes,
eso es lo que evaluamos,
ese caso empresarial,
esa toma de decisiones,
análisis de indicadores, de gestión,
retorno de inversión, no técnica,
de negociación,
también según qué proyecto.
En esa semana es que ustedes estén
haciendo el caso.
Si tienen dudas y necesitan apoyo por
parte del profesor,
pueden contactar con el profesor las
veces que lo necesiten y el mes lo
dividimos en cuatro.
Entonces dos casos sí que serán de manera
individual, pero luego siempre.
Siempre tiene dos casos grupales que hay
para aprender,
para interactuar con gente del sector
bancario, sector farmacéutico.
¿Eso pienso que es lo más enriquecedor
que encuentran en o b s vale?
Y por último, trabajo final de máster,
que es hacer un plan estratégico,
un plan de negocio donde apliquen todo lo
visto en el programa.
Este va a ser un proyecto que va a ser
tutorizado.
Se les asigna 1 de los profesores,
quien les va a ir guiando el proyecto
haciendo las revisiones y al finalizar se
presenta mediante un tribunal en línea.
Vale,
y este fue un proyecto mira de un colega
mexicano. Él estudió otro Máster,
coaching directivo y liderazgo.
Pero bueno,
más o menos para que veas un ejemplo,
es esto,
hicieron un trabajo final de máster y la
presentación es así grupal. ¿Entonces,
qué es lo interesante?
Pues mira que aquí hay alumnos de más de
5 países que hicieron ese trabajo grupal.
Vale,
y sobre todo la presentación del proyecto
final.
Es como si ustedes estuvieran presentando
un proyecto ante inversores.
Hay que hablar de números, de retorno,
de inversión,
porque invertir en ese proyecto,
como si tú presentaras un proyecto en
Nestlé,
no el desarrollo de algún producto, no,
porque es viable invertir.
¿Qué investigación has hecho? ¿O sea,
es un proyecto aplicable a la realidad
empresarial de los alumnos, vale?
Y por último,
apoyamos también el máster con estos dos
boot Camp que son adicionales,
pero estos dos Boot Camp sí que son
específicos para el programa de de
marketing de dirección de marketing y
gestión comercial.
Hay un simulador de marketing que es un
Business game.
No sé si alguna vez trabajaste con
simuladores de negocio. No, no,
todavía no vale este simulador.
¿Hay simuladores muy buenos,
este de Harvard,
que es básicamente es un juegos de roles
a nivel de una empresa, vale?
Y el siguiente boot Camp es del plan de
marketing.
Vale que este es clave para el trabajo
final de Master y es eso que te decía
como vender un proyecto ante inversores,
que esto para la parte de negociación te
te ayuda mucho.
En la parte de negociación, sí,
en o b s hacemos encuentros directivos,
hacemos Company, bici.
De hecho estuvo estuvo en el año pasado.
¿Siempre se hace con alguien de Nestlé,
vale marketing?
En el área de marketing también son en
vivo y en directo.
¿Ustedes los pueden ver en vivo y en
directo o los pueden ver grabados y no
pudieron estar en ese momento conectados,
pero casi siempre son todos a las 7 a las
a la hora que te dije 11 12:00 h del
mediodía hora de México, vale o KY?
No sé si viste esto,
no sé si te llamó la atención esta página,
no sé si la llegaste a ver.
Ya no llegué hasta allá, pero o sea sí,
o sea está interesante no que también se
tienen intercambios, no solo, o sea,
no solo nos quedamos con una,
sino también con otras universidades.
¿Exacto,
tenemos un intercambio con el TEC de
Monterrey, vale,
en qué consiste este se llama Coil
Collaborate Online Learning Qué hacemos
con alumnos del tecnológico de Monterrey,
donde durante 3 semanas se trabaja en
casos de marketing y ética en los
negocios?
¿Y si lo finalizas recibes este
certificado emitido por el TEC?
Vale que De hecho te voy a contar una
cosa que me pasó a mí súper Chévere.
¿Este alumno que matriculé yo el del
proyecto final, le pregunté yo, oye,
cómo nos conociste? Y me dijo,
él estaba haciendo un envíe en el TEC y
me dice, Oye,
porque hice una actividad con o b s
conocí al o b S por 1 actividad que
hicimos online y me encantó y era esto el
coil, Ay,
qué padre o K entonces me encantó. Sí,
entonces tenemos el convenio con ellos.
Este es el software con el que trabajamos
para el Business Game,
Marc Mark Strat y por último,
la graduación.
Sí que hay un evento presencial aquí en
Barcelona y es la graduación.
Los grados son siempre en el mes de julio.
¿Entonces, cómo se organiza?
¿Se hace una semana,
dónde se viene aquí a Barcelona?
Se hacen visitas empresariales,
se hacen cursos de inteligencia
artificial aplicados a los programas.
Y por último, la ceremonia de graduación,
que es un evento bastante importante,
protocolario,
siempre se invita a un directivo,
alguna persona importante en El Mundo
empresarial a nivel mundial.
De hecho el este, el este año, perdón,
ahora en junio se va a invitar al a una
eminencia,
pues en tema de negocio de una
multinacional muy importante,
que es el Grupo Puch,
que son los dueños de Carolina Herrera,
o sea empresas súper Tops. Vale,
va a estar ahí con gente padrino de
ceremonia compartiendo con los alumnos.
¿O K o K qué vale? ¿Entonces,
qué sería lo bueno?
¿Te explico por qué sería interesante que
pudieras entrar a abril y no octubre?
Porque si tú empiezas ahora en abril,
terminas en abril 26 y a los dos meses
vienes al grado,
mientras que si inicias en octubre
terminarías octubre del 2026,
pero tu grado te tocaría en el 2027.
¿Claro, claro,
claro o K es eso lo que puedes poner en
una balanza?
Luego claustro docente.
Nosotros no trabajamos con el típico
catedrático que solo se dedica a clases
en una Universidad, no son practitioner.
¿Qué quiere decir profesionales en activo
que trabajan para importantes
multinacionales?
Porque eso es lo que enseñamos,
los casos reales,
lo que se está aplicando en la realidad
empresarial, no teoría.
Tienes profesores internacionales, vale,
por ejemplo, Genevapuritas de Argentina.
Ella es espectacular.
Ella trabaja también en otros máster como
el de marketing digital,
lidera proyectos espectaculares.
Y bueno,
aquí está el LinkedIn de cada 1 de ellos.
¿Luis toro también es una eminencia muy
bueno, Eh?
Carreras profesionales son todos los
servicios que tienes en o b s totalmente
gratis en el momento de tu vida
profesional,
donde estés tienes una cantidad de
servicios y actividades que te ayudan a
alcanzar ese crecimiento profesional.
¿Vale, y bueno,
no sé si hasta aquí tienes alguna
pregunta, no, no, no, qué te parece?
¿Te hace sentido, te gusta?
Si, si, si si está padrísimo, o sea,
desde que vi el el plan de estudios,
yo dije,
es prácticamente como bien platicábamos
al inicio de la sesión lo que necesito,
no tanto tema de marketing como también
de account to Management,
entonces sí me llamó bastante la atención
y bueno,
ahorita ya con lo que complementas pues
ni decir no, o sea todavía mucho más,
me alegra. ¿Bueno Andrea,
qué necesitamos para la admisión?
Tu currículum ya lo tengo, me lo descargo,
De hecho está muy bien.
Solo necesitaría una foto de tu documento
de identidad,
puede ser el pasaporte o algunos alumnos
de tu país me envían el el INE de México,
eso se llama exacto y bueno,
me mandaste el currículum en PDF también
fabuloso que ya lo tengo, vale,
ese sería el primer requisito,
luego esta entrevista,
yo pienso que tienes perfil,
eres óptima para este programa ahora,
aprovechando que mi responsable ya me
respondió,
te comento la parte financiera tuya tu
una pregunta que que eso es importante
también saberlo.
¿El máster lo vas a hacer por tus propios
medios, tienes apoyo empresarial,
cómo tenía apoyo familiar, perdona,
cómo tenías pensado hacer frente a la
inversión?
Sería justo combinado entre apoyo
familiar y de mis ingresos. ¿Vale,
porque mira el máster,
no sé si viste el valor público,
es este €7500 esto lo sabías? ¿Cómo ves?
Ajá. ¿Cómo ves la inversión?
¿No está, o sea está bien, está bien Paul,
porque precisamente como platicábamos,
o sea realmente son o sea son inversiones,
obviamente no cuesta lo de 1 m b a,
pero eso son inversiones, o sea fuertes,
cuando ves que son de instituciones pues
de prestigio no?
Pues mira para la para ahorita me para
ponerte ahorita en el en el de abril.
Sí que me comenta que el cupo está
disponible,
son un cupo que tiene 3 descuentos
financieros que equivalen a un ahorro.
Como si te hicieran un descuento de €2370,
es decir €2370 tendrías un descuento de
casi 54000 MXN$,
con lo cual tu Master te bajaría a €5130
que son 5130 serían 116700 MXN$ pesos o k.
Vale,
en este valor en estos 5130 está incluido
todo, o sea,
no tienes que hacer ningún pago por
aparte,
ni pagar el título ni derechos de grado,
nada está todo incluido. ¿Vale,
y cómo sería la forma de pago?
Tendríamos que hacer un primer abono del
10 por 100,
que esto si se pudiera hacer el día de
hoy mejor,
porque así te matriculo y te dan de alta
las claves para que te pongas al día.
Ese 10 por 100 sería un primer pago de
€513, es decir.
Esto que se puede pagar 11600 pesos por
tarjeta de crédito de débito Visa
Mastercard American Express por un link
que yo te envío o KY el importe restante
lo financiamos, es decir,
lo dividimos en 13 mensualidades a pagar
sin intereses y a partir de mayo,
entonces así cada cuota esto dividido en
13 te quedarían cuota de 355,1535 5,
15 serían cuotas de unos 8000 MXN$.
O K 1084 pesos.
Qué te parece sí o sea sí lo veo bastante
viable,
precisamente como te comento Pau iban a
hacer este inversión conjunta,
no tanto familiar como mía,
la verdad es que lo veo bastante bien,
entonces ya ahorita mismo me comunico con
mi papá que es quien me estaría ayudando
y ya sí,
sí este si gustas aún así Mándame el link
porque lo más probable es que sí,
sí está entrando y ya para que te podamos
dar este primer abono de primera
instancia.
¿Perfecto este primer abono lo pagarías
con tu tarjeta o la de tu papá?
Este primer abono a lo mejor y hasta con
la mía.
Pau vale de todas maneras también a modo
estratégico también para que para que se
lo comentes a tu papá también.
Nosotros cuando hacemos matrícula,
cuando tú hagas la matrícula,
después hacemos la matrícula online las
dos.
Hay una cláusula que se llama período de
desistimiento,
es la cláusula número cuatro.
Esto aquí en yo no sé si hay en México se
maneje,
pero tú te matriculas pagas tus €513 y si
por ejemplo no estás seguro en iniciarlo
ahora,
De hecho eso te sirve a ti a modo de
clave de que estos 15 días pruebes a ver
cómo te sientes.
Si no te llegas a sentir bien,
podemos coger y el expediente y pasarlo
sin ningún coste para que lo inicies en
octubre y ahí ganarías tiempo.
Yo te lo recomiendo para que sepas eso,
que los 15 días es un periodo de
gestimiento,
que si tú quieres rescindir el contrato
se te devuelve todo lo que pagues de
matrícula también. O sea,
no perderías el dinero como si quisieras
pagar en este momento,
pagas en este momento y si a lo mejor tu
papá te dice que no se puede rescindir el
contrato y se te devuelve todo lo que tú
hayas pagado de matrícula,
no pierdas la matrícula. Vale,
entonces esos 15 días sirven tanto como
desestimiento como para Cambiarte para la
siguiente apertura.
¿Perfecto o k listo,
entonces porque me toca pedir
autorización y habilitar el niño,
tú puedes hablar,
a qué horas hablamos aquí?
Ya es un poquito tarde,
pero te soy sincera,
yo tengo más cosas que hacer,
tengo que mandar varios mail,
o sea no te no te cortes si hablamos en
un ratito yo no sé si en 1 hora tú me
puedas decir algo para enviar, sí, sí,
yo ahorita mismo le marco a mi papá,
no te preocupes y más tardar a la una de
acá yo ya te tendré respuesta.
¿Sabes qué voy a hacer también para
facilitarnos la vida a las dos?
Te voy a mandar mi Whatsapp,
que creo que no te he escrito por
Whatsapp para que nos vayamos comunicando
por allí y para que me mandes allí la
foto de tu documento de identidad te
parece y te voy preparando yo la
matrícula vale,
igual te mando ahorita todos los correos
con el resumen vale,
pues nos vemos ahora en un ratito. Andrea,
gracias,
gracias PA Discúlpame sólo una duda
rapidísima este bueno me imagino gracias
a que este bueno chico está o bueno
rescindió.
¿Es que se tiene este apoyo académico?
¿No? O sea, sólo quería ver,
o sea si tengo,
o sea si tendría que darnos algo
adicional o a lo mejor y por mi perfil es
que tengo como este derecho a este apoyo
académico, o sea, sólo funcionar, digo,
sólo entender perdón un poquito cómo
funciona y bueno,
o sea ya lo de las parcialidades me quedó
súper claro,
sólo ver si ejemplo cuando son apoyos
académicos,
luego se dice o K tienes que mantener un
promedio mínimo tomame el ejemplo de 9.
No solo quería ver si hay como alguna
condición, no te explico,
este descuento es un escalado de
descuento,
ya lo ya lo verás cuando salga la hoja de
matrícula.
Hay un 20 por 100 que es por fecha de
matrícula porque él se matriculó en los
primeros cupos,
luego hay un 10 por 100 que tiene él,
que es una ayuda que da o b s a alumnos
por perfil profesional.
En tu caso trabajas en una buena empresa,
has tenido una buena trayectoria,
eres merecedora de ese 10 por 100,
luego él tiene otro 5 por 100,
que es una ayuda también empresarial.
Vale,
pero en tu caso cumples el perfil con lo
cual puedo puedo. O sea,
ya me he autorizado mi responsable que
puedo utilizar ese cupo para ti o KY duda
Pau. O sea, en caso que esté,
no sé saliendo de Nestlé, o sea, aún así,
tendría o sea derecho a este sí.
Sí, te apoyo, claro, sí, mira,
una vez tú haces tu matrícula te va a
salir una hoja de matrícula,
una se llama así hoja de matrícula,
que eso es un contrato,
entonces por tema contractual no te
podemos modificar ese contrato y es más,
si tú decides cambiarte para octubre no
se te modifica cada año,
los máster se revalorizan,
cambian de valor como ya estás
matriculada,
eso se te tiene que respetar e incluso la
cuota. Si Decides moverte a octubre,
la cuota no empezaría en ahora en en mayo
porque ya empezó el programa.
Empezaría en septiembre,
octubre o K vale o K se te respeta,
es un contrato que tú has firmado,
con lo cual no se modifica. Vale, vale,
listo, todo listo,
pues entonces te mando los correos YY ya
te mando mi contacto también vale o k
perfecto, lejos, muchas gracias,
vale hasta ahora. Chao bye bye.